I was coming up with your back coat you  take mine I take yours police but no  same rule heyo pops Watchers let me take  the Beemer out this one time  you'd like that wouldn't you it's gone  CJ's birthday Academy so I know you  finished the investigation registration  I'd like to know what you plan to do  I'll speak plainly based on everything  our investigators family the officers  involved would not be charged in any way  it's us and then Mary it's always been  awesome man it's right and wrong cuz I  CJ had a gun  of excess all the internal files let me  see what I can do my son got shot by the  same officer she shares how would you  show me that so why shouldn't I shoot  you right now  why should I drop you you could or you  could ride with me  [Applause]  why over sunny six years old  you  you